are you looking to invest in property or
maybe not even invest in property but
escape your job and have more time by
being a property entrepreneur well in
this book which is a best-selling book
by low rent hi I have given a lot of
different strategies around property but
there's so many different strategies
sometimes it's hard to decide exactly
what to do so in here I've selected the
best 3 property investment strategies
and actually not just giving you the
this is what you can do but giving you
the step by step how to do it ABC I've
also included what to say so there's
some scripts in here so how to speak to
agents how to speak to motivate to
sellers where to find them how to find
them
so I think the reason this book is a
best-seller and it's sold tens of
thousands of copies across the UK and
the world is because it actually gives
you the how-to rather than just
explaining what you can do so hope you
enjoy it while I'm on a mission to help
people become financially free this year
alone I've helped 76 people leave their
jobs and become financially free so I'm
going to give you this for free on one
condition
wellnot on two conditions first is you
have to pay the pnp which is 2 pounds 9
but the book is a gift second condition
is you need to apply the information in
here and when you apply and when you
become successful drop me a Facebook
message and tell me because your success
is my oxygen enjoy the book click the
link below I'll see you real soon